we have identified nine core
characteristics that mark an individual
as having high potential
drive the unrelenting need for
achievement and constant
self-improvement
resiliency the ability to persevere in
the face of challenge and bounce back
from setbacks
adaptability the ability to adjust
according to the situation
learn new things innovate and try new
methods
humility self-confidence in one's
ability while understanding that there's
always room for improvement
and that others experiences and
knowledge are valuable
integrity and in head and adherence to
not only what is legal
but also what is right effective
intelligence the ability to apply one's
knowledge to real world scenarios team
ability
the ability to function as part of a
team placing the success of the whole
above the needs of the self curiosity
a desire to explore the unknown and
question the status quo in pursuit of
better
more effective solutions and the last
one is
emotional strength a positive attitude
high empathy
and control over one's own emotions
especially in chaotic and stressful
situations
these traits are heavily emphasized in
special operations and explain why many
veterans go on to accomplish incredible
things in the business world
after their military service for
instance many companies including
johnson and johnson with alex gorsky
fedex with fred smith bridgewater david
mccormick and 711 joe depinto to name a
few
are run by veterans these nine
attributes are foundational to success
no matter the industry so when you say
based on
our research and interviews is this
stuff that doc
dr cotton kind of put forward or where
did you guys come up with these
so it's a combination of what dr cotton
uh sort of his discovery and then we
also went
and we interviewed people that ran the
assessment selection for these different
communities marsoc the navy seals the
green berets we worked with
a uh amazing individual his name is
brian decker
he was a lieutenant colonel he was in
charge of the
special forces assessment and selection
process and actually sort of
revolutionized it
really around the concept of the whole
man concept and so
each of these communities have a set of
core attributes they're looking for and
it goes back really quickly
you did make a point about people you
know you hire somebody who interviews
extremely well
and they end up not working out and
that's what we call personality versus
character what you did was you hired
based off personality and likability and
what is personality that's really your
external uh sort of uh show to the world
where characters the the inner uh
attributes that drive your behaviors
yeah and we've
all fallen for that it's like you're
you're uh you're customer facing
self versus your internal facing self
exactly in in
you know one of the things we talk about
in the book is like the last thing you
want to hire for and people get this
you know this culture fit are they a
culture fit and it sort of becomes this
just
ad hoc term they throw out but they
don't really understand
and when people say culture fit a lot of
times what they mean is do i like this
person
and what we talk about in the book is
that some of the
the most high performing seals that i
served with and you serve with
i didn't like we were professionals and
worked well together
but when the job was done he went and
hung out with his inner circle and i
went along with mine
but likability for professionals is not
a requirement
now if you guys just conflict and it
creates a toxic culture that's a
different thing but
the least important thing to me was
likability if the individual performs
and he can actually put his self needs
aside or her self needs aside
for the common good of the team that's
somebody that can be part of the culture
as long as their values align
with our culture ethical yeah i mean i
think
here's the deal on that from my
perspective if there's someone
that works hard and is there to support
the team
i like them you know like
i i i don't know anyone that has
here's here's the interesting thing i
know people that have
good personalities and bad character
they exist
but i don't know of anyone and so i
might not like someone that has a good
personality but you know and you you can
think when i think of these people i
just think of famous people right
there's all these famous people that
they have these personalities and then
they then all of a sudden the story
breaks
that they're total dirtbags right and
they're whatever they've got
the most heinous things going on in
their personal lives
so you've got that where someone has a
good personality their their
forward-facing
personality is real positive but then
behind closed doors they're scumbags
and but if you flip that over i can't
think of anybody that has
a good character like they're a good
character
but they're a bad but they have a bad
personality i don't i don't
it's hard for me to think about now is
there someone that maybe has a has a
a good character and they're they're
maybe too direct or maybe they're
maybe they don't talk a lot or you know
whatever but but normally
if they've got a if their egos in check
if they're there to support the team
i mean i can't
yeah it's pretty rare yeah how about a
better way of putting it is there were
people that were high performers that
were just sort of socially awkward
so maybe they were introverted or just
like they were too direct right where
it burned sometimes bridges you
understood their personality but other
people didn't
it back to the uh the attributes so
brian decker is now
the director of player development for
the indianapolis colts
and so took what he learned in special
forces assessment selection he's now
applying it he's been in the nfl he's
worked for for two teams for about six
years
when they revolutionized and and you
know
it pains me to say this but i can put my
ego aside
the special forces army special forces
community
was much further ahead in terms of
creating a
structured and professionalized
assessment of how they select
special forces uh soldiers into the
community seals it was just sort of this
oral history passed down
and uh when i went over there as a guest
instructor
at their phase two which is their small
unit training that's when i was really
exposed to their whole process and this
thing called the whole man concept
and the fact that they were looking for
specific attributes
so when they redesign their their
assessment and selection
they created tasks much like an
interview process
where they're trying to elicit certain
behaviors whether good or bad
and that's what they're looking for and
so that translates to
companies it doesn't matter you know
what your interview process is or if you
have written tests
what you're trying to elicit with every
every question should have meaning
behind it in an interview process
and ultimately that question has to
drive at behaviors
that's and people call this you know in
the civilian world behavioral interviews
they're one of the best techniques if
you do it well
yeah the uh the german army as they were
trying to
get their their officers to step
up and implement decentralized command
and be able to make moves
one of the things that i've read about
they would do is they would give them
here's the rules that you have to follow
for this training operation
and the only way that they could
actually successfully complete the
mission would be to break the rules
and so it was a test to see if they
would break the rules
in order to accomplish the mission and
then there was and look
even if you if you didn't break the
rules
it didn't necessarily mean that you were
a bad person it just
now we know more about you right now i
know
more about you and you know we got into
some of this on uh when we're up at
gettysburg for for ef battlefield
you know the fact that lee didn't know
his his two subordinates as well
as he had before jackson died so he's
talking to ewell
and he's telling you all that he wants
to do something but he doesn't know him
well he doesn't know his personality
well enough
so when he tells you hey take that thing
if you can't take that hill if you can
and yule goes over and says well i can't
he could have it just would have been a
gut check and
if he would have told jackson to take
that hill jackson would have taken that
hill
so these are this idea behind setting
up questions or situations or problems
that you have to solve that
reveal some part of your character
is a very cool thing you know when you
mention earlier about when people come
to you and ask
what's the best interview question the
question back to them is
how are you screening for character it's
one of the things we go into this book
is that
most of those questions are about
experience
do you have this objective experience
they're
not screening for character and so you
know with the research that we did with
dr josh cotton brought to us and when we
figured these out you know our point is
is that you know once you meet that
simple experiential gate
when you've got the basics you need to
start screening for character
and you go company by company by company
and
and i and i hate in some ways to say
this because i see it all the time which
is
executives are almost the worst of this
picking other executives
and they don't screen for character
they're looking for did you work at the
competition
how did you move the revenue how did you
improve customer success how did you
move a product along
they don't go down into character and i
s i've sat in the interview after
interview after interview
and it and it's all objective traits or
you know basic subjective traits that
don't go deep into character
and that's what's missing
people will default to objective things
because they're measurable yeah they're
easy it's it's the easy button
the subjective is what's hard he talked
about
defining success you know one of the
mistakes we see with companies too is
they just have one interview process
across the uh the organization you
actually have to create
talent profiles for each of the roles
and functions and levels of
and that's why it takes a lot of time so
what's going to make a great engineer
in a company is vastly different from
what makes a great sales person
so a lot of the times why companies
don't define success and they're not
good at the
interview process is they haven't take
the time to create talent profiles for
the different levels
in the different functions within the
community